[Musique]
bonjour à tous et lundi point de vue
revient on est ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau rendez vous d'actualité
avec quatre sujets que nous allons vous
présenter tout de suite en images après
la publication sur les réseaux sociaux
de ces images très violentes d'un
adolescent braquant son professeur de
nombreux témoignages circule sur twitter
de d'enseignants qui disent qu'il ya eu
une volonté d'étouffer ou en tout cas de
minorer de tels actes y at il une forme
de loi du silence dans l'éducation
on en parlera on parlera aussi de la
stratégie d' attaque qu'à ses offensives
de jean luc mélenchon contre les
journalistes ça provoque des réactions
très vives de la profession mais c'est
peut être payant politiquement on vous
demandera votre point de vue puis on
parlera aussi de ségolène royal peut
être est ce par dépit de ne pas être
revenu au gouvernement en tout cas la
tacc bille en tête le pouvoir actuel en
lui reprochant de faire de l'écologie
punitive notamment en augmentant le prix
du diesel on en parlera et puis on
parlera de la prise de position de la
crise muriel robin en faveur de la
gestation pour autrui
suivent en cela notre confrère marc
olivier fogiel
quand les people prennent position dans
le débat public est ce que ça influence
l'opinion voire même peut-être le
législateur on en parlera avec nos
quatre invités bonsoir anne fulda ravi
de vous retrouver dans cette émission
vous êtes grand reporter au figaro on se
spécialise dans la politique mais pas
que puisque vous êtes aussi la
responsable de tous les grands portraits
du quotidien et vous êtes l'auteur d'un
portrait d'une biographie même de
référence sur emmanuel macron un jeune
homme si parfait aux éditions plon
marins de virer là aussi bonsoir vous
êtes écrivain critique littéraire membre
du comité de direction de la revue des
deux mondes est votre dernier ouvrage un
roi immédiatement a été publié aux
éditions pierre guillaume deux roues
chars bruit de bonsoir ravis de vous
accueillir vous êtes expert à la
fondation jean jaurès spécialisés
notamment sur le sujet de sport et de
société vous êtes d'ailleurs co auteur
du livre le foot va-t-il exploser co
édité aux éditions de l'aube et de la
fondation jean jaurès si vous êtes par
ailleurs premier adjoint socialiste à la
mairie du 2e arrondissement de paris et
puis à roanne en est là bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes consultant en
stratégie
j maître de conférences à sciences po
chroniqueur chez nos excellents
confrères de l'opinion est votre dernier
livre la france des opportunités toutes
les bonnes nouvelles qu'on ne vous dit
pas été publié au balo lettre c'est bien
ça et il ya non il n'y a pas eu de livre
depuis j'avais un doute pas encore migré
sur moi en préparation on n'en saura pas
plus on commence avec cette actualité
lourde sur les violences à l'école
vous avez certainement vu ces images qui
date de jeudi dernier où un adolescent
de quinze ans tient en joue son
professeur avec un pistolet dont on a
appris par la suite qu'il était tard air
comprimé ça se passe au lycée edouard
branly de créteil et l'élève demande à
sa prof de la notte présent sur la sur
la liste haddock
après cette image cette publication qui
a fait l'objet de beaucoup de réactions
politiques y compris du chef de l'état
il y à un hashtag qui s'appelle acheta
pas de vagues et sur lesquelles un grand
nombre de d'enseignants explique que eux
aussi ont été confrontés à des
situations de violence et qu' ils n'ont
pas fait état
ou alors que leur hiérarchie a voulu
étouffer ou en tout cas minorer ce genre
de ce genre d'événement anne fulda ce
que vous croyez qu'il ya un souhait de
l'éducation nationale peut être de 2,2
mètres un peu le couvercle sur ces
problèmes de violence scolaire
il paraît qu'il ya 400 incidents par
jour donc qui eux sont déclarées
clairement ça fait ça fait des années
que qu'on tente de minorer ce qui se
passe dans certaines écoles faut pas
généraliser effectivement dramatiser
mais il faut pas non plus ignorer ce qui
se passe est clairement on va pas
revenir sans cesse sur ce livre qui
n'étaient pas sur la les violences de
cet ordre là mais quand même ce fameux
livre des territoires perdus de la
république qui pointait déjà une forme
de violence par l'antisémitisme par
la perte d'autorité des professeurs et
finalement ce qu'on voit là c'est une
autre expression d'une perte d'autorité
qu'on constate un petit peu partout
c'est à dire et puis un renversement des
airs archi c'est à dire qu'on voit que
la parole des adultes est totalement
dévalorisé la parole de celui qui
représente l'autorité à l'école c'est à
dire le professeur est aussi dévaloriser
donc clairement on a l'impression qu'il
ya eu pendant des années un déni ou
sommet de l'état une manière de refuser
de voir ce qui se passait et et
probablement des consignes de dans les
écoles de minimiser de minorer ce qui se
passait vraiment sur ces images
richard bruit qu'on voit ce professeur
alors peut-être qu'elle est en état de
sidération qui a l'air comme résigné
devant ce qui se passe à elle ne réagit
pas mais c'est vrai que c'est l'autre
l'autre image choc je trouve de cette
séquence vidéo il ya à la fois celui qui
braquent cette arme factice contre d'un
professeur il ya la réaction de la
professeur qui a été tout autant je
crois qu augmenter avec beaucoup
d'analystes mais c'est compliqué
d'analyser sereinement et de l'analyse
et justement c'est ce que m'a dit
qu'elle est très traumatisés exactement
est ce qu'elle est très traumatisés est
ce que c'est quelque chose qui relève
d'une espèce de fatalité d'une habitude
on ne sait pas on sait que dans ceux
dans cet établissement en tout cas ses
collègues ont dit que ce n'était pas des
établis en établissements à problèmes
dans lequel il y avait ce type de
situation qui ce qui se produisait
régulièrement
moi je trouve que on est dans un moment
où il fallait bien évidemment qu'il y
ait une réaction de la part de du
gouvernement jean michel2 lancker l'a
fait a dit qu'avec son collègue
christophe castaner il y aurait une
action d'envergure y aurait un comité je
crois stratégie qui se mettra en place
tout ça est très bien mais je pense que
la nature de la réponse va être
importante d'abord parce que dans l'en
tête que vous signaliez sur les 442
incidents par jour qui avait été réalisé
par la fève en 2017
c'est une situation qu'on montrait que
les principales violences étaient
d'élèves à élèves et pas forcément des
lamas professeur sall ne minore pas les
choses mais ça veut dire que si on veut
s'attaquer globalement à la violence
dans des établissements il ne faudra pas
se limiter à la violence que subissent
et des professeurs qui doit être
condamnée jubilé bien évidemment mais
aussi à celle qui a lieu entre les
élèves et qui pour une bonne partie
d'entre elles est aussi importée des
violences qui existent dans les
quartiers où sont implantées certains
établissements
qui sont un moment donné aussi
confrontés à des situations de violence
dans la vie alentour dans la vie du
quartier et l'école de ce point de vue
là n'est pas ce havre cette enceinte de
paix qui à un moment donné 200 que faire
on en est on n'en est plus là moi sur la
vague qu'on a eue le pas de vagues la
vague d'émotion avec pas de vagues
je pense qu'il faut voir à l'intérieur
il y avait différents types de réactions
c'était des type de violence très
diverses mais on sentait bien qu'il y
avait une volonté de la part des
enseignants d'être mieux écouter mieux
prises en compte
je pense que depuis quand même les
années chatel je pense qu'avec peillon
et notamment l'émission qui l'a mis en
place il ya eu cette volonté de mieux
former les inspecteurs de mieux former
les dizaines de mieux former les chefs
d'établissement il ya un progrès qui a
été fait il est aujourd'hui je pense
insuffisant mais dire qu'il n'ya pas une
prise de conscience sur une maladroite
après c'est comment se traduit cette
prise de conscience qui je crois est
aujourd'hui le phénomène qui est
reproché par une partie de la communauté
éducative et notamment par les parents
d'élèves la fcpe notamment mais la peine
avait dit la même chose
s'inquiétait beaucoup des types de
réponses qui était donnée de manière à
ce que les faits divers ne dicte pas à
chaque fois les lois ou en tout cas les
décrets qui sortent au bon ou au mauvais
moment
même si dans les témoignages dont on
vous passe quelques extraits à la sur
twitter il ya des professeurs qui se
plaignent aussi de des parents qui sont
parfois au moins aussi agressif que que
les enfants marin de viry ya un une
proposition du ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer de
d'interdire les téléphones portables
aussi dans les lycées ça qu'on sait que
ça va être désormais le calme dans les
collèges
on vous sait d'ailleurs la question du
jour sur le figaro.fr et vous êtes très
majoritairement aura de façon écrasante
favorable à cette interdiction
parce que dit le ministre le sait images
postées sur et asociaux ça fait partie
du problème
alors moi je suis pas d'accord avec ça
mais mais c'est votre point de vue qui
m'intéresse c'est à dire que moi je
pense que ces vidéos sur les réseaux
c'est plus la conséquence de la violence
que la cause ou alors c'est le reflet
c'est un symptôme mais ça n'est pas
l'origine mais c'est peut-être pas votre
point de vue non c'est pas mon point de
vue parce que je pense qu'il faut pas
négliger les phénomène mimétique enfin
qui voilà qui sont propres à l'âge très
jeune
enfin ces personnes sont très jeunes qui
ont entre 12 et 16 ans quand il se met à
basculer dans la violence points
les phénomène mimétique sont importants
d'imitation d'imitation d'un modèle
voilà et puis enfin je voudrais juste
revenir sur la question de la chape de
plomb qui règne sur le sur les
professeurs j'ai lu il ya quinze ans un
livre qui s'appelle portrait de
professeurs en territoire difficile
d'aymeric patricot je sais pas si ça
vous dit quelque chose c'est vraiment un
livre remarquable sur sa sur le fait que
tous les jours les professeurs étaient
agressés verbalement physiquement et
c'est que l'administration organisait en
fait la vague le mans du niveau
hiérarchique supérieur c'est-à-dire
celui du rectorat et l'éducation
nationale
c'était absolument enfin un statut mans
clair le mécanisme était très très bien
démontés la deuxième chose que je dois
dire là dessus c'est que le problème de
ce garçon c'est pas tellement le
problème de l'éducation nationale c'est
le problème de sa famille c'est quand
même de sa famille il n'y a pas de pacte
entre l'éducation nationale et la
famille de ce garçon aussi en avez un et
bien il se comporterait pas comme ça
d'une certaine façon et c'est là où le
fin pour moi ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure et très juste mais
fondamentalement ski areski a fait
réussir l'éducation nationale
contrairement à ce que disait d'ailleurs
castaner castanheira dit c'est le
berceau de la république l'éducation
nationale mais c'est pas vrai c'est pas
le berceau c'est le creuset c'est à dire
c'est un deal entre un deal ou un
contrat entre la république et puis les
familles parce que les femmes y
mettaient leurs enfants l'éducation
nationale avec toutes une tout un tas de
perspectives positives pour leurs
enfants
aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas c'est les
familles ne met plus leurs enfants dans
l'est dans ces écoles avec des
perspectives positives pour eux donc le
problème c'est la famille de ce garçon
lui même évidemment il en subira les
conséquences c'est bien normal mais
c'est surtout sur ce travail alors
qu'ils font ce travail là qu'il faudrait
faire renoncer il ya une responsabilité
des familles certains disent par exemple
il faut supprimer les allocations
familiales des familles dont les enfants
se comporte mal je crois que
effectivement il ya la responsabilité
des familles jetées comme excuse
l'éducation nationale je me fais plan
caire comme été
le recteur de l'académie de créteil ne
traitant pas avait mis en place un
dispositif s'appelait le que la mallette
des parents choix et donc avait il avait
mis non mais il avait fait des remous de
valverde non non il y avait sept
adhérents des amants séparés d isa
soucier il associer les parents à la
scolarité de leurs enfants collégiens
avec des réunions régulières une forme
de contrat vous très explicites et ça
avait des effets immédiats sur le alors
c'était sur l'absentéisme des enfants je
ne dépasserai des cas d'une intelligence
mais sur l'implication des parents dans
dans la vie scolaire
moi je crois pas je pas très favorable à
la sanction des à la suppression des
allocations à des sanctions sur les
parents des amendes pourquoi pas la
suppression des allocations
je sais pas si c'est la bonne solution
après il ya effectivement une énorme
responsabilité d'éducation nationale
énorme
moi j'ai eu pendant dix ans il ya dix
ans pardon j'ai créé une association qui
coachait des lycéens de zep pour se
préparer au concours de sciences po donc
des talents formidables
on a fait rentrer 150 gamins à sciences
po en disant je suis passé la main
maintenant mais il ya entre eux il ya
dix et cinq ans quand je vous en occuper
on voyait les établissements d'île de
france d'abord ils sont comme vous le
disiez extrêmement différents c'est pas
parce qu'elle le lycée et en aide qu'il
est nécessairement difficile il ya des
difficultés sociales mais il n'est pas
nécessairement violent et puis à paris
la séance est non mais on sait qui va
lancer dire voyez ce qu elle a les
quartiers difficiles il y a
c'est donc une très grande diversité
après vous avez des établissements où il
ya des chefs d'établissement qui assume
la responsabilité et d'autres ou ne le
font pas vous avez des établissements
j'ai vu des établissements pendant l'été
les manifs contre les retraites 2003
contre les lycéens étaient extrêmement
mobilisés par un sujet qui les touche et
les coudes directement et il avait donc
fait des vues dans un lycée que je
connais bien fait des manifestations
hyper violente lancée d d d d extincteur
sur leurs camarades depuis les étages et
c est le proviseur avait refusé de
revenir des conseils de discipline parce
que ça allait créer des tensions parce
que les proviseurs sont mal notés
quand ils signalent des problèmes ils
sont pas incités à le faire parce que ça
a nui à l'image de l'établissement
hextadon vous avez d'aider des
professeurs des proviseurs qui met qui
démissionne de tellement de leurs
responsabilités le même établissement
quelques années après à changer le
proviseur et j'ai vu moi le proviseur
qui étaient à l'entrée qui demandait aux
gamins de rentrée l'heure de ranger
leurs téléphones portables sinon ils
n'entraient pas dans l'établissement
mais ça change tout alors je dis pas que
ça résout tous les problèmes de violence
mais il avait un moment cette autorité
dont on parlait elle s'incarne vous avez
un certain nombre de responsables de
l'éducation nationale de la hiérarchie
des enseignants qui ont totalement
démissionné
et puis vous avez aussi des enseignants
c'était le cas dans cet établissement
qui sont militants très marqué à gauche
et qu'il a quand un conseil de
discipline avait été organisée ont porté
plainte parce qu'ils estiment que c'est
une atteinte à la liberté d'expression
de l'enfant qui avait violenté ses
camarades donc l'éducation et celle via
xts énormément de complexité il ya
effectivement je crois aujourd'hui un
discours qui est intéressant au niveau
national mais de là à ce que je
redescende
jusque dans les lycées c'est complexe et
après pour dernier point on je suis
assez modérément convaincu par les
annonces
enfin les déclarations du gouvernement
je trouve ces petits pics de la pauvreté
des débats publics on a un événement sur
les réseaux sociaux on réagit on annonce
un grand plan b c'est pas un grand plan
on va créer une commission va faire un
livre blanc entretenir une certaine
confusion quand on voit ce flux d'image
des réseaux sociaux je dis juste
rapidement où on voit il ya un gamin qui
fait un doigt d'honneur et il ya une
semaine la ce qui tournait c'était deux
autres grands gamins qui faisait un
doigt d'honneur autour du président des
règles week donc c'est vrai qu'il ya
toute une une échelle des valeurs qui
est totalement bouleversée aujourd'hui
et notamment à cause des réseaux sociaux
il faut c'est un point important je
pense ce que vous disiez maintenant sur
les la mentalité des enseignants alors
ça vous voyez ça faisait un petit peu
réagir il faut pas généraliser mais par
exemple dans le figaro de ce matin il ya
un collègue de ses profs du lycée
edouard branly qui dit bah oui la fin
alors qu'on réagisse moi je pense qu'il
allait dire il faut qu'on comprenne des
mesures d'exclusion un nouveau règlement
intérieur et dit non il faut qu'on
réfléchisse à notre méthode pédagogique
enfin les profils ont un petit peu peur
d'être et on peut les comprendre
peut-être dans ce registre de la
sanction parce que pour eux c'est un peu
un constat d'échec quand même pour
certains d'entre eux après je pense
qu'il ya aussi beaucoup d'enseignants
qui est de profs qui vivent la réalité
au quotidien et qui met aussi un petit
peu ces principes très très théorique de
côté néanmoins dire
en complément de ce qui a été dit qu'il
faudra aussi que les professeurs soient
peut être mieux formés sur la gestion de
certains groupes et de personnalité
difficile dans un groupe à la gestion de
conflits et c'est dire qu'il faudra
aussi que les bugs l'école évolue sur
ses méthodes pédagogiques
oui ça ne répond pas à la situation
qu'on a vu là mais dire qu'à un moment
donné on s'arrêterait en chemin en
disant que c'est uniquement dans la
gradation de l'échelle des sanctions
qu'on va trouver la réponse je pense que
ce serait une erreur
si ça doit être un grand plan ce grand
plan devra apprendre et la partie des
sanctions et la partie de la prévention
s'il n'y a pas les deux jambes là encore
une fois je crois que ça va être un plan
qui comme les autres
ce serait une réaction spontanée à un
fait divers très intéressant mais ça
n'ira pas plus loin
aujourd'hui dire que la solution
passerait par le fait qu'on va supprimer
des postes au lycée ou au collège je
pense que ce n'est pas une solution dit
que c'est moins de référent adulte je ne
pense pas que ce soit une solution par
contre dire qu'à un moment donné il faut
aussi que l'éducation nationale met
davantage en place un système d'écouté
pour les enseignants qui sont victimes
tous les jours de petites violences et
qui a cumulé à un moment donné se font
que le le vase explosé déborde et qu'on
a beaucoup de situations de preuves qui
seront obligés de s'arrêter qui vont pas
bien ça oui je pense qu'il faut qu'on
sache un peu mieux le prendre en compte
on le fait aujourd'hui pas forcément la
grande mêlée silvio l'enfer j'ai
aujourd'hui un des leurs qui parlait
aussi dans une interview de ce week-end
de responsabiliser les parents on va
voir en quoi en tout cas nos internautes
ont ont des idées un jeanne nous dit les
élèves qui ont ce genre de comportement
de votre être dirigée dans des maisons
de correction alors aujourd'hui on
appelle ça des centres éducatifs fermés
mais ça existe et arrêts des allocations
familiales pour les parents
ces allocations serviront alors à payer
le séjour du délinquant
nicole nous dit pendant des années les
enseignants ont refusé les sanctions
adéquates il en paye le prix aujourd'hui
et pierre lui considère que
l'interdiction des portables dans les
lycées n'est pas la priorité dans cette
affaire heureusement que cette vidéo a
fuité ajoutent ils on passe à un autre
sujet médiatique jean luc mélenchon a
été l'objet la semaine dernière lui
puissant parti d'une perquisition de la
police judiciaire en réponse il s'en est
pris assez violemment
non seulement aux policiers mais aussi
aux journalistes et notamment à nos
confrères de radio france qui était
revenu sur des financements des
surfacturations en tout cas présumés de
sa campagne présidentielle jean luc
mélenchon n'avait pas l'intention de se
laisser faire
écoutez comment il s'adressait à notre
corporation
c'était vendredi dernier et ils étaient
dans le taxi qui l'amenait à l'assemblée
nationale vous avez là non sa valeur
après les autres
c'est ce que c'est quoi ces animaux quoi
il y en a c'est comme les moutons qui
courent donc france info a démarré sur
comment la mystérieuse les comptes de la
campagne trop cher ça tombe mal c'est la
moins chère des hommes donc ils ont
l'air de ce qu'ils sont c'est à dire
d'abrutis relayé relayé sans arrêt pour
hisser les parcs ou oui parce qu'il faut
qu'on obtienne au moins un résultat
alors comme jean luc mélenchon fait
quatre à cinq vidéos par jour on
s'emmêle un peu les pinceaux donc celle
là il n'était pas dans le taxi il en
était descendue mais sur le fond c'était
la même chose les journalistes sont des
abrutis pour hisser les parts ou marin
de viry ce que ça peut être une bonne
stratégie finalement politique
on sait que les journalistes sont pas
très aimé dans ce pays si on regarde
toute la séquence moi je suis absolument
fasciné parce que j'ai l'impression que
l'exécutif le pouvoir attaque le
législatif c'est-à-dire les assurés par
les partis les parlementaires et les
parties avec l'aide du judiciaire et le
législatif pour se défendre ne trouve
pas d'autres moyens que d'attaquer les
journalistes enfin donc il ya un
problème général en fait d' équilibre
des quatre pouvoirs en fait dans ce pays
c'est ça que ça me 5 ça me donne comme
impression générale c'est-à-dire une
impression de confusion quatrième étant
dans l'organisation même le quatrième
étant les médias oui absolument de
confusion de l'organisation même disons
d des pouvoirs
cette confusion dans une ambiance où en
gros d' insulte de faux mépris de 10
réflexion agressive et cetera bon donne
ce que ça à la séquence de la semaine
dernière et ça va continuer avec
d'autres
donc moi le cas de mélenchon ne
m'intéresse pas particulièrement
il se trouve que comme il est
particulièrement volcaniques
ça donne des séquences il intéresse les
médias etc
mais fondamentalement il ya un prêt de 2
d'organisation de
comment dirais-je des différentes
institutions entre l organisation d
équilibre des pouvoirs parce que les
médias n'ont jamais été considéré comme
un mec comme un pouvoir constitutionnel
comme chacun sait est la différence de
l'autorité judiciaire et de deux autres
pouvoirs et le regretté gasquet oui oui
c'est qu'ils en convent ce que je pense
c'est qu'il faut c'est qu'il faut passer
à la vitesse supérieure c'est à dire
qu'il faut véritablement s'emparer de la
question du pouvoir des médias et de la
traiter à fond dans leurs notes dans le
rapport des médias avec les différentes
avec les différentes institutions
personne personne perd 5 arrivées selon
vous qui devrait s'en va paraître
s'isoler on va dire ça
ce qui devrait s'en empare et les
médiums à un grand débat de société au
parlement dans les parties et c'est pour
dire que ce pouvoir exister que
aujourd'hui il est manifestement pas sa
place
en tout cas il produit pas quelque chose
qui soit utile au service de la
démocratie
on vous a posé la question sur twitter
un condamné vous les attaques de jean
luc mélenchon à l'égard des journalistes
c'est oui à 73% et alors la france a
soumises a fait une espèce de vidéos ce
week-end ça c'est même pas une espèce et
une vidéo tout court alors ça ressemble
un peu au mur dès qu'on peut être du
syndicat de la magistrature
en tout cas ça pointe un certain nombre
de confrères qui ont eu la malheureuse
idée de s'en prendre parti regardez en
termes vulgaires ça me semble un pétage
de plombs on est abasourdi bourgi dit en
voyant ces images je suis sans voix je
sais pas quoi dire quand même quel
comportement ils exagèrent
il est dans l'excellent est dans
l'outrance c'est inédit je pense c'est
total un tel niveau
c'est proprement stupéfiant ce convoi on
est monté d'un cran parce que là c'est
d'une violence
ça a été vraiment physique ça a été
parfois du corps à corps
[Musique]
alors non moins il assume un les gens de
la france a soumise à oui oui mais tu te
fais mais ces deux temps plusieurs
années que tout leur propre
communication est fondé sur suscité
l'indignation ils passent leur temps à
dénoncer les riches s'en mettre plein
les poches
ils ont fait avec quelques années avec
stéphane hessel un best-seller sur
indignez vous et là maintenant il
s'indigne que les gens qu' on puisse
utiliser éventuellement l'émotion sur le
sujet sur leicester sur les journalistes
qui le montre sauf erreur de ma part la
majorité d'entre eux sont 1
ce que je comprends quand une fonction
particulière t il son éditorial il se
sent les auditeurs ce sont des gens des
journalistes dont le métier est de
commenter la vie politique de l'éclairer
avec leurs regards sont des gens que
quand on entend brunet on sait qu'ils
parlent avec un une peu dur avec un
point de vue qui affirmait quand même
personne ou alors il faut être vraiment
très bien informé mais lui même ne s'en
cache pas donc je pense que il ya là ils
ont fait un choix spécifique ses palais
n'est pas les mules j'en extrais métiers
de l'information et qui informe après ce
que les journalistes ont des biens d'un
format des des biais dans leur façon de
travailler leur façon de faire parce que
on leur reproche régulièrement
manque de diversité idéologique ça oui
mais c'est un os est un autre sujet qui
pour moi ne justifie pas le ne justifie
pas le comportement de jean luc
mélenchon je suis pas complètement
d'accord avec vous tenir je suis pas
convaincu qu'il ya un problème ça
renvoie un problème d'équilibré des
pouvoirs et moi je m'intéresse à la
personne de jean luc mélenchon parce que
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui a fait
qu' à quelques centaines de milliers de
voix près alors le se voyait présent la
république n'aurait pu être second tour
de l'élection présidentielle représente
une part une force politique qui est
très importante et on a là quand même un
comportement
outre l'excellent kick un extrêmement
inquiétant sur sa vision de la
démocratie
il ya une phrase de stendhal qui est un
dans la chartreuse de parme son
exagération le porta naturellement la
tête de son parti
difficile à dire car la france a soumis
souffrent pas seulement aux
éditorialistes
elle reproche aussi à des journalistes
des points assez précis par exemple les
gens de mediapart ont fait état des
relations personnelles qui existait
entre sofia chic et où est jean luc
mélenchon ce fichier raw qui était chez
jean luc mélenchon le tôt le matin quand
les policiers sont arrivés chez lui or
se fait chic euros est aussi soupçonné
de surfacturation de la campagne jean
luc mélenchon mais est-ce que sur ce
point là est-ce que vous pensez que
journalistes ont raison de faire état de
ce lien ou alors qu'est ce que c'est
privé mélenchon dit ça vous regarde pas
vous devriez pas en parler dans le cas
en l'espèce
les deux informations semblent liés quoi
sinon effectivement il n'y a pas de
nécessité de donner une information sur
la vie privée et on peut pas dire que
dans la tradition française ça soit
enfin sauf depuis quelques années en
fait très savoir mais pendant longtemps
il ya eu une espèce d'autocensure quand
même bon là effectivement étant donné
qu'il semble y avoir des liens entre les
fonctions que rock avait madame chic et
roué et qu'elle avance
il y aurait aussi des liens plus privé
avec avec jean luc mélenchon on peut se
dire que ça peut se justifier mais est
ce que ça apporte vraiment quelque chose
de l'eau au moulin s'adjuge je suis pas
convaincu cela met sa menace que plus
intéressant tout le vocabulaire qui
utilisent mélenchon est dite pour hisser
les bains il est toujours sur la
rengaine de masse et la rengaine de tous
pour y accéder les médias la justice les
flics tout le monde est donc c'est quand
même un vocabulaire assez dangereux
surtout que comme c'est quelqu'un
d'intelligent mélenchon il
il pointe aussi quelques quelques faits
qui sont pas toujours faut par exemple
quand il parle des médias qui sont
parfois moutonnier c'est vrai qu'il ya
parfois des médias qui sont moto nier
c'est à dire qu'il mêle dans une espèce
de de magma virulent et et coléreux
quelques quelques vérités c'est ça qui
est dangereux chez lui quand elle a au
fait de s'en prendre aux médias c'est
vrai quand les temps sont mauvais c'est
c'est un peu quelque chose de facile
c'est pas le seul à le faire pendant la
présidentielle il ya marine le pen l'a
fait françois fillon l'a fait et
aujourd'hui encore il ya peu de temps
emmanuel macron l'a fait aussi au moment
de la faire des malheurs
il n'y a pas qu'en france 1 que les
responsables politiques s'en prennent
aux médias ça peut être payant puisque
je crois que à part les politiciens les
journalistes sont partis d'eux les
corporations des plus détesté des
français
on voudrait vous montrer cette image cet
extrait c'est un discours un meeting de
donald trump
il est en campagne vous savez qu'il ya
des élections qui arrivent aux états
unis il est dans le montana et part d'un
de ses amis qui s'appelle greg gianforte
y viennent forte c'est un c'est un
membre de la chambre des représentants
et il est républicain et il avait
l' idée un peu saugrenue de flanquer par
terre un journaliste en l'occurrence du
guardian qui lui avait posé une question
qui le dérangeait sauf que ça arrive
juste avant une élection est la trame se
dit zut
ou peut-être un peu plus ça va
l'empêcher d'être élu et c'est pas du
tout ce qui s'est passé et rome s'en
réjoui regardez comment ils racontent
l'histoire windows
elle est où le voyage anoman taipei
world ait été riche en ovation du public
quand il raconte que son ami greg
gianforte et à flanquer journalistes par
terre c'est les trucs qu'ils pourraient
pas arriver en france ça ce genre de
scène je sais pas tel que c'est quand
même mis en scène par par trump je ne
pense pas mais les temps précise c'est
un c'est un meeting républicain
oui justement enfin je pense qu'il ya on
est en six dans le meeting on est avec
trump qui adore ce genre de mise en
scène et on voit bien aussi toute la
réécriture de l'histoire parce que
finalement ce n'est peut-être pas
exactement ce qui s'est passé ce qui est
en train de nous raconter ça n'a
peut-être pas coûté suffisamment cher au
candidat républicain pour que finalement
il soit élu mais on ne sait pas si cette
image là ne va pas lui coller à la peau
à un moment donné donc il ya une mise en
scène de strub une réécriture et qui
correspond à la base militante des
républicains aujourd'hui qui est
effectivement mais depuis des mois très
encouragés à s'en prendre à la presse
c'est aussi la victoire de la france
insoumise vous croyez je ne sais pas ce
que je sais c'est que on a quand même
des témoignages ariane chemin l'avait
dit récemment où on montre surtout ça et
finalement une stratégie qui a été mise
au point et moi ce que je remarque dans
ces images qu'on a eu depuis quelques
jours c'est que finalement jean luc
mélenchon très intelligent effectivement
a mis en scène tout ça il fait un
facebook live de sa perquisition
imaginez si françois fillon avait fait
quelque chose de ce genre là aussi le
modem avait fait quelque chose de ce
genre là au moment où ils ont été eux
aussi ils ont eu à subir des
perquisitions non là il met en scène
quelque chose et cette mise en scène là
en fait est fait pour à la fois
galvaniser les troupes
et en même temps je pense qu'elle est le
mais malheureusement sur une stratégie
électorale complètement complètement
abracadabrantesque pour le coup parce
que je pense qu'ils gagnent en statut de
leader de la france insoumise mais en
termes de présidentiable je pense qu'il
y perd beaucoup mais c'est une stratégie
je pense que c'est voulu s'est
entretenue depuis plusieurs jours il ya
cette volonté alors en plus ce qui est
paradoxal qui est que la classe
politique on sait n'est pas très
considéré de la part des français que
les journalistes ne le sont pas
pas davantage ou très peu très peu très
peu plus donc bon bref tout ça pour dire
que c'est un petit peu un jeu qui est
étonnant et c'est en même temps et ça
vient il faut le dire quand même
aujourd'hui ça dans un contexte où les
partis politiques ont via les réseaux
sociaux des moyens de s'adresser au
public qui sont pas les canaux habituels
et où certains ont créé leur propre
chaîne des médias et donc je pense que
jean luc mélenchon ça peut s'affranchir
d'autant plus insolite d'ailleurs assez
en avant ça n'en est pas un de very
c'est intéressant parce que c'est à la
fois il a pris à la fois une posture de
victime et en même temps il a fait
l'éloge de la violence politique
les deux la posture de victime ça aurait
pu fonctionner mais dans son système il
faut aussi qu'ils aient une
il faut aussi qu'il y ait un volet si je
peux dire offensif et ce volet offensif
c'est la violence politique et je suis
totalement enfin l'apologie de violences
politiques même je suis d'accord avec
vous pour penser que dans les urnes
ça ne passe pas ça ne passe pas parce
que j'aurai ferment alors ça passe par
quoi donc ça au fond ça le ca le sale
mais à l'extrême gauche encore plus et
je ne vois pas du tout ce qu'ils
recherchent a traversé à quelques
commentaires d'internautes sur
lefigaro.fr et sur twitter hashtag point
de vue hashtag figaro life nicole nous
dit mélenchon à des indignations à
géométrie variable selon que cela le
concerne ou pas babineau nous dit
mélenchon et comme trump ils essayent de
renverser la vapeur la meilleure défense
c'est l'attaqué
et puis christophe qui fait ce
commentaire n'y at il pas une différence
de traitement sur les perquisitions
entre les partis politiques en france
d'être christophe faites vous allusion à
une remarque faite par l'anp wauquiez
dans une interview donné hier à nos
confrères du parisien laurent wauquiez
expliquant que presque tous les partis
ou des enquêtes sur le financement de la
campagne présidentielle sauf emmanuel
macron alors même qu'ils avaient eu des
signalements en ce sens de la commission
ad-hoc
on reste dans la sphère politique
française pour s'intéresser quelques
instants à cette déclaration de ségolène
royal l'ancienne ministre de l'écologie
était ce matin l'invité de nos confrères
de rtl
et elle l'a cognée assez fort voire même
très fort sur le gouvernement
regardez quand du jour au lendemain vous
mettez plus 4 centimes sur l'essence et
plus de 7 centimes sur le litre de
diesel c'est énorme
est-ce que du jour au lendemain les
automobilistes peuvent vendre leur
voiture pour acheter une voiture
électrique une voiture hybride la
réponse est non il a cassé tous les
leviers positif de l'écologie positive
et aujourd'hui ils cherchent à justifier
une hausse fiscale un matraquage fiscal
par l'écologie et ce n'est pas aux
neiges alors la malraux cible des
attaques de ses cadres s et bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie ronan
est ce que vous partagez ce constat le
gouvernement fait tout les choses à
l'envers c'est iron l'écologie
impopulaire en augmentant les impôts en
l'occurrence les taxes sur le le diesel
je partage le constat mais sans le
jugement moral c'est à dire que
ce que je ne comprends pas ségolène
royal sait que si on considère que la
pollution c'est ce que les économistes
appellent une externalité négative je
pollue mais c'est vous qui payez parce
que on ne peut pas me l'attribuer à moi
seul donc la solution économique pour
que le jeu pollue moins c'est qu'à un
moment je paye le coût de la pollution
si on estime que le gasoil ça pollue le
rôles moins cher que l'essence à polluer
ben c'est normal de taxer le gasoil
c'est normal de faire des bébés des
péages à l'entrée des villes sont estime
qu'il peut qu'elles polluent trop dans
paris c'est normal de taxer les
comportements qui polluent
personnellement j'estime qu'on a un
niveau d'impôt absolument spoliés à
thouars dans ce pays et donc ça ne
devrait pas augmenter plus est à bout
alors son second mandat du volet bc
ailleurs mais là où super accord avec
ségolène royal c'est qu'on peut pas
dénoncer la logique de taxer la
pollution c'est la logique même de la
fiscalité écologique sauf que richard
goode donc ça veut bien invoquer un élu
parisien
les gens disent ouais mais nous on prend
notre voiture parce qu'on pourra faire
autrement et puis c'est pas de notre
faute si c'est un diesel on n'a pas les
moyens de m'acheter une autre juste
peut-être que l'extrait complémentaire à
celui qu'on a entendu ségolène royal
expliqué que dans la loi sur la
transition énergétique voter en 2015 et
que normalement nous n'étions encore il
y avait une obligation qui est que quand
on mettait une taxe sur l'écologie on
enlevait une taxe par ailleurs ce qui
fait que pour les français il y avait
une taxe neutre qui était que l'écologie
ne soit pas vécu comme étant une
écologie punitive mais comme étant dans
la participation à quelque chose d'autre
ce qui veut dire que c'est comme ça
qu'elle ne justifiait et quelque part le
constat on le connaît il est que s'il
est facile pour un parisien dont je suis
nous avions déjà eu cette discussion
d'avoir abandonné sa voiture
par ailleurs je suis aveyronnais et
j'habite dans un village de 200
habitants ou si je demande aux
agriculteurs aux personnes qui habitent
dans ce d'abandonner le diesel ce n'est
pas possible
or on les a encouragés pendant des
années a acheté un diesel plutôt que
d'acheter de l'essence
ils ne peuvent pas du jour au lendemain
avoir un comportement qui les amène à
acheter un autre véhicule
quels sont aujourd'hui les aides que le
gouvernement maintient les at il
d'ailleurs maintenu non on le sait
c'était une autre partie de l'interview
de ségolène royal et ne les as pas marre
tout ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui pour
avoir la possibilité de changer son
véhicule à essence ou diesel pour un
véhicule qui est moins polluant on n'a
plus les aides qu'on avait précédemment
ainsi
a sion à changer les comportements ça
devait être un peu ça normalement la
taxation écologique mais avec des aides
sinon un moment donné on coince des gens
et moi quand je vais dans l'aveyron on
me dit tu es bien gentil
à paris c'est facile de laisser ta
voiture mais nous on ne peut pas la
laisser et je suis au regret de dire
qu'ils n'ont pas tort parce que les
transports collectifs n'existe pas et
c'est pas le car qui existe une fois ou
deux fois par semaine qui résoudra le
problème pour les personnes qui vous
pose la question à sur twitter ségolène
royal estime que le gouvernement cherche
à justifier un matraquage fiscal par
l'écologie selon vous at elle raison et
vous ne répondez oui à 68%
jack no 10 en réponse à cette question
madame royal a la mémoire courte
elle a utilisé les mêmes méthodes anne
fulda c'est vrai que le budget carburant
c'est très important à ses 1700 euros
c'est l'équivalent du salaire mensuel
médian en france donc il ya des bonnes
intentions de la part du gouvernement
mais n'empêche que pour les gens ça tape
au portefeuille
je trouve qu'elle est très efficace
politiquement ségolène royal quand elle
rit quand on écoute quand on est comme
souvent
alors il ya peut-être effectivement
certains disaient de la rancoeur mais
admettons et façon cet aspect là en tout
cas c'est très efficace intelligible et
audible cette démonstration parce que
effectivement
on est obligé de se dire bon ben voilà
c'est un peu toujours les mêmes qui
payent et c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas ce
qu'elle disait aussi dans la suite de
l'interview il n'y a pas de mesure qui
qui permettrait par exemple une tva à
zéro pour cent si on achète une voiture
électrique de mesures effectivement
d'écologie positive à ça et ça les gens
comprennent très bien donc il ya pas de
discours global sur l'écologie positive
et il n'y a pas de mesure non plus donc
là dessus elle a raison en même temps à
un biais on va pas se mentir l'écologie
positive ça veut dire distribuent de
l'argent aux gens et ne l'a plus oui oui
non mais c'est pour ça qu'elle a tapé
très juste parce qu'il ya un effet
trappe c'est à dire que en réalité on ne
peut que subir la hausse il n'y a pas
d'alternative à au fait de subir la
hausse parce qu'il n'ya plus les
dispositifs est donc cet effet être à
plat il joue sur les gens modestes donc
on punit les pauvres et donc il tape
très juste sur le plan politique c'est
du ségolène royal absolument
chimiquement plus chimiquement pur et
vraiment il ya rien à dire c'est c'est
très bien mais c'est efficace si elle
est en passe d paul roll d'ailleurs lé
terme c est au loup ambassadrice père
paul lavoie d'annoncé c'est si on veut
que les français aient leur conversion
écologique il faut leur donner des
subventions des aides et sinon on n'y
arrivera pas mais il ya deux versants de
l'ariel premier versant qui consiste à
taxer les comportements dont on veut
plus à sanctionner les comportements
dont on veut plus et c'est ce que
la logique de la fiscalité écologique et
après vous avez un versant qui est
prospective bien on va transformer les
modes de consommation et les habitudes
et là effectivement il ya une solution
qui peut être d'inciter certains
comportements vertueux né à côté vous
assistez l'autre mais le problème c'est
quand vous deviez on n'a plus un rond on
a plus aujourd'hui d'argent pour
financer c'est celle là est donc là là
c'est pour ça qu'il est plus simple
aujourd'hui pour le gouvernement de
taxer selon qu'il veut plus que de
soutenir des plans de transformation
ensuite effectivement je pars il n'a pas
donné l'impression jusqu'à maintenant
d'avoir mis les questions
environnementales aux transformations
écologiques au coeur de sa vision de
société
et puis il ya quand même une belle
question de politique d'aversa anne
fulda ya est ce que pour protéger les
générations futures
il faut sanctionner les gens qui vivent
aujourd'hui après tout pourquoi est ce
que la vie de ceux qui viendront après
nous a plus de valeur que que la nôtre
si on n'arrive plus à boucler ses fins
de mois si on n'a pas de moyens de
transport alternatifs les gens moins
central des gens ça n'existe pas des
gens mais ceux qui sont victimes de ces
mesures là où un sentiment profond
d'injustice
oui c'est vrai qu'il faut c'est très
difficile d'avoir des mesures générales
effectivement faut penser aux
conducteurs de qui habite dans l'aveyron
en dehors dordogne en auvergne comment
il fait quoi donc on est obligé de
prendre en considération tout ça mais ce
qui manque je trouve au delà de la
difficulté c'est que c'est vrai qu'on a
eu on a des grandes déclarations
du type de celles qui avaient fait de
chirac ailleurs on a des vidéos après
l'accord de paris qu'elle ait fait
notamment de sept hommes avaient fait
macron à l'adresse de trump mais on n'a
pas globalement un discours
responsabilisant c'est à dire je trouve
que c'est étonnant
on avait pourtant nicolas hulot qui
était censé être le représentant en
écologie
on n'a pas eu un discours qui met
vraiment les choses à plat et qu'ils
disent à tout le monde mais voilà on en
est là et maintenant c'est à chacun de
faire des efforts c'est c'est comme ça
on n'a plus le choix
alors moi j'ai une hypothèse que je vous
soumets c'est qu'en fait les gens n'y
croient pas ce qu'ils disent oui bien
sûr il ya un problème mais ils ne se
sentent pas coupables quand ils prennent
leur voiture et est en fait ils ne sont
pas ils n'ont pas un sentiment
d'inquiétude ou de d'urgence suffisant
pour modifier leur comportement mais
c'est peut-être notre pardon une société
française vous qu'un décret sur la
société de défiance ou on a l'impression
que si on fait un effort on est une
société que de de resquilleurs et donc
si je suis le seul à faire ne sait même
pas que je crois pas au réchauffement
climatique c'est que si je fais des
efforts de toute façon tous les autres
triche
donc pourquoi est ce que moi je le ferai
je vais attendre que les autres s'y
mettent et puis comme personne ne s'y
met au final rien ne bouge mais il ya
une défiance profonde des français les
uns et les autres au delà des questions
environnementales qui fait qu'ils ne
sont pas spontanément au courage et à
responsabiliser et comme pour illustrer
ce que vous venez de dire on a un
commentaire de nicole qui nous disent
sur les réseaux sociaux on tape sur les
voitures mais pas sur les avions et les
porte-conteneurs on les paquebots de
croisière géant qui pollue un max
exactement le kérosène est toujours pas
taxées enfin je veux dire quand à un
moment donné on fait une augmentation
sur la taxe qui sont celles du diesel ou
de l'essence pour les pères les
personnes c'est très bien mais le
kérosène aujourd'hui pourquoi ils
échappent pourquoi même kérosène n'était
pas compris dans les accords de paris
pourquoi un moment donné quand on n'y
croit plus et qu'à un moment donné on a
aussi la sensation du deux poids deux
mesures les plus gros pollueurs
aujourd'hui ce sont notamment les avions
et c'est ce qui échappe à une taxation
qui pourrait être puni si vous puissiez
au positive on verra et le terme mais en
tout cas qui échappe à une taxation
quand on a des personnes qui elle tous
les jours vont être taxés pour aller
chercher de l'essence alors même que
pour certaines existent sont contraintes
pour pouvoir juste aller bosser
donc oui un deux poids deux mesures qui
encouragent cette espèce de deschamps
c'est l'air de dire à un moment donné
pourquoi toujours les mêmes seraient
amenés à être les responsables aient
atterri à devoir taxe et non après c'est
un dalle j'avais envie de citer céline
il disait presque tous les plaisirs des
pauvres sont interdits et c'est vrai
dans cette affaire d'écologie on dans la
bonne impression que c'est ce que m'a
dit un jour ce sont les plus modestes
qui vont payer le plus de fait et c'est
pas les grands industriels qui vont
profiter largement ce ne sont pas les
classes qui ont accès aux loisirs qui
vont profiter d' axa banque était là
elle a très bien elle a très bien ciblé
comme d'habitude on taxe beaucoup par
exemple de tabac et on sait
qu'aujourd'hui le tabac était est plus
fin il ya plus de fumeurs dans les
catégories populaires que que dans les
dents les autres alors un dernier
commentaire de 6 qui nous dit soyons
sérieux
y'a que c'est pas grave n'a qu'à faire
50 km en vélo matin et soir pour aller
au boulot passe à un autre sujet le
gouvernement dans le cadre de la
révision des lois de bioéthique a prévu
d'instaurer la procréation médicalement
assistée pour les couples de femmes ou
pour les femmes seules
en revanche emmanuel macron l'a dit et
répété il n'est pas question d'autoriser
en france la gestation pour autrui c'est
à dire les mères porteuses mais il ya
des personnalités médiatiques qui font
campagne pour la gp 1 c'est le cas
notamment de marc olivier fogiel notre
confrère de rtl qui avec un livre sur ce
sujet pour raconter son expérience
personnelle
samedi dernier sur le plateau d'on n'est
pas couché l'émission de france 2 muriel
robin actrice et humoriste est venu en
quelque sorte conforter fogiel en
égratignant du même coup un autre
chroniqueur de l'émission qui s'appelle
charles consigny et qui lui est contre
la gpa on revient sur ce sujet mais
d'abord on regarde les images je trouve
que c'est formidable d'être alleaume je
crois de quelque chose qui c'est parti
la machine est lancée et éthique pas été
parfois malheureusement son livre m'a
beaucoup éclairé que je me dis tiens
donc il ya des femmes tu pas que j'ai
raison et qu'il ya des femmes c'est
peut-être possible
la cour dit
on pense dans l'afrique un enfant qui
arrivait enfin tout le monde parce que
ce que pour ça je peux vous voulez dire
simplement
d'après vous la parole parce qu'au bout
de vous dire l'arrogance ça me fait mal
finalement
voilà l'arrogance c'était pour charles
consigny marin de viry c'est étonnant
parce que ce disque on l'aï se développe
il se déroule presque naturellement
alors même qu'on pensait qu'il y avait
un consensus contre les mères porteuses
comme il la force de ces personnalités
ou leur aura était supérieure à sa oui
quand on lit même le rapport du conseil
d'éthique mais cela il exclut totalement
la gpa mais c'est pour mieux dire que la
pma c'est formidable effectivement on
pensait que c'était on pensait que
c'était été exclu moi ce que j'en pense
simplement c'est que ils sont pas
qualifiés quoi ils sont pas qualifiés
pour ouvrir un débat démocratique
ils sont pas qualifiés pour parler de
sujets qui sont des sujets
anthropologiquement quand même très
lourd puisqu'il s'agit de la enfin de la
dispersion si je peux dire de la
reproduction enfin delà du fait que
l'enfant ne naît pas d'un père et d'une
mère
que comme elle dit et je suis frappé
quelqu'un mais qu'elle convoque
l'anthropologie africaine là dessus et
qu'elle dise un enfant en afrique qui
naissent et l'enfant de toute la
communauté donc pourquoi pas deux femmes
enfin ou pourquoi pas deux hommes ou
pourquoi pas d'une communauté parce que
tout est permis avec la gpa on n'y a pas
le choix quand vous ils sont pas
qualifiés marc litt fogiel part de son
expérience personnelle il est même
homosexuel marié et il a deux petites
filles nées de mère porte très bien et
il va donc raconté que c'est le bonheur
et que ça super etc et on connaît tous
des gens qui ont ce genre d'expérience
et c'est pas le problème le problème il
est enfin là après mille politique
la question c'est de savoir quelle est
la règle et ce qu'on accepte cette idée
que des enfants soient faits à
l'extérieur complètement à l'extérieur
de ceux qui ont ensuite devenir leurs
parents au sens social du terme et cette
règle lors elle ne peut pas se discuter
dans paris match en fin juillet où est
la qualification de paris match ou et le
uss la qualification de paris match et
la qualification de fogiel ou et la
qualification de celle qui l'a de muriel
robin enfin d'une certaine façon pour
qui se prend-il c'est ça qui m'a moi
c'est ça qui me fascine qui pour qui se
prend-il du point de vue de l'art
expertise de leur rapport au débat et de
comment dirais-je leur capacité à
intervenir sur quelque chose d'aussi
important d'aussi grave et qui concerne
l'ensemble de la société et même ses
fondements anthropologiques enfin j'y
vois là on parle de fogiel et muriel
robin on parle pas de là on parle de
gens qui sont sympathiques mais qui
n'ont pas forcément des idées très
approfondie sur le saut vers une fuite à
que ce sont des personnalités
extrêmement populaire et dont la voix
compte et alors effectivement ils ne
font pas la loi comme vous intitulé le
sujet n'est pas question qu'ils fassent
la loi en revanche si son identité la
loi c'est d'avoir médiatique voilà il
faut écouter parce qu'ils font la loi et
ils sont écoutés par les responsables
politiques parce qu'effectivement ils
ont une certaine popularité
il représente dans une certaine mesure
l'air du temps donc dans une certaine
mesure
l'air du temps donc tendance est donc
ils sont quand même écouté alors après
c'est pas eux qui vont influencer mais
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on voit voilà marc
olivier fogiel il a il a eu accès grâce
à son livre c'est vrai qu'il a à la une
de paris match il a tf1 il a besoin de
tous les grands médias donc
obligatoirement au bout d'un moment
c'est ça fuse quand même dans la société
ça peut aussi créer des réactions
contraires mais ça peut aussi créer de
l'empathie de la compréhension
donc il faut voir que il ya 30 ans par
exemple on voyait pas non plus de
couples homosexuels dans les séries télé
enfin c'est c'est de cet ordre là c'est
la société qui bouge et de temps autant
la société bouge avant les lois alors ça
veut pas dire que c'est eux qui sont
légitimes pour la faire bouger mais ils
peuvent participer à la faire bouger et
fabrique vous pensez qu'il ya une une
forme de stratégie c'est à dire que par
exemple on peut penser que fogiel sort
son livre au moment où il ya la
discussion de la loi sur la pma parce
que lui est favorable à ce que on aller
encore plus loin ont d'abord le débat
sur la pma et
régulièrement repoussées donc je veux
dire il l'a peut-être pas non plus
calculer exclusivement là dessus en tout
cas je ne sais pas ses motivations par
rapport à ça moi ça me donne comme
impression c'est que on a un peu
interdit le débat sur la gpa et je pense
qu'on est dans une société aujourd'hui
où on ne peut plus bannir a priori un
débat ça doit être quelque chose qui est
conclusif et par introductif c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui on a dit la gpa non
mais sans aller dans le débat lui même
et je pense que quand on fait ça
aujourd'hui cette société ne tient pas
sur cette valeur et c'est en gros c'est
tabou si à un moment donné n'y a pas de
démonstration s'il ya pas d'affirmations
s'il n'y a pas d'argument or aujourd'hui
le risque de ne pas avoir fait le débat
de ne pas l'avoir porté avec les
difficultés qui a parce que y'a le débat
théorique mais il ya aussi le sort par
exemple des enfants qui sont nés de gpa
et qui existent et qui sont bien là
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie question et
qui mérite aussi d'être posée peut-être
dans d'autres termes d'ailleurs que
celles de certaines émissions télé mais
est ce que finalement à interdire un
débat on sait pas donner aussi un moment
donné les moyens entre guillemets
d'avoir des faux débats d'avoir des
débats qui sont mal posée et qui sont
portés par des personnes qui certes ou
un rapport personnel avec le sujet mais
qui ne le pose pas avec la distance qu
aurait mérité ce débat on l'a eu déjà ce
sentiment là eu au moment du pacs on
nous a dit non mais pas le mariage vous
savez ce sera pas possible au moment du
mariage pour tous et de l'adoption on
n'a surtout pas la pma finalement la pma
on va avoir le débat et ça va faire un
espèce et là tout d'un coup il ya la gpa
et je pense que interdire le débat sera
un moment donné nous a mis dans une
situation compliquée parce que je pense
que la société a besoin à un moment
donné qu'on n'arrive pas simplement sur
il ya un tabou mais plutôt il ya une
démonstration et on arrive au final à
dire que on est sur ce débat moi j'ai
vraiment cette sensation qu'aujourd'hui
ceux qui portent le débat le porte parce
qu'il n'est pas poser ailleurs de
manière sérieuse
oui sauf le nom que là le débat s'ouvre
mais les anticiper à ils font pas la une
de paris match parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
notoriété de marc-olivier projet lors de
l'émission de ruquier il
ce fait pas la série bat vraiment je
vous savez une partie du débat politique
il ya des personnalités s'engage là pour
cette je vais appeler cette cause mais
il y en a plein qui s'engagent pour
plein de cause alors personnellement que
ce soit celle là où d'autres ça ne
m'intéresse pas parce que je suis pas
influencer par ne sont pas influencés
par le fait que madame bernadette chirac
aime les pièces jaunes donc
muriel robin est une tradition sur la gt
r non mais voilà mai mais effectivement
ça suscite
ça contribue à 1,15 accor a incarné une
cause est compté et à la rendre
populaire sûr mais quelle est la
capacité contributive
excusez moi mais c'est dans le débat de
muriel robin et de faire et je suis
d'accord mais non mais c'est sûr avec
vous mais francesco pas non plus de
raison de deux légitimes de larrau
qualifiés non plus ne sont pas à
disqualifier oui c'est pas se mettre à
leur place c'est à dire à la place de
témoignages d'une expérience heureuse
pour fogiel très bien parfait ça doit
exister voilà mais met donc ça fait
partie du débat si les baisses il ya une
personnalité
il ya des personnalités qui se sont le
plus proches des opposants à la gpa
qu'elle s'exprime est ce que la question
sera est-ce qu'il y en a et à ce
qu'elles le font et pourquoi elles le
font pas est ce que le débat se fait de
manière serein ce raid est ce que toutes
les positions peuvent s'exprimer de
manière équitable je ne suis pas
complètement convaincu mais là on a vu
aussi que les opposants à la gpa cij et
considère pas raccourci que c'était les
mêmes que ceux posés à la manif au
mariage pour tous donc la manif pour
tous
ils sont trouver les moyens de se faire
en tant qu il fallait se faire entendre
c'est ça fait partie du débat
démocratique ya plusieurs façons de
s'exprimer personnellement je joue pas
il peut battre est un grand enthousiasme
des deux de ces débats j'ai pas vu
connais pas cette émission donc j'ai pas
eu 20 voix la montre et c'est tous les
samedis soirs avec laurent ruquier les
commentaires sur twitter
selon vous ça c'est la question qu'on
vous a posé les personnalités publiques
ont-elles une influence dans les débats
sociétaux bas vous ne répondez oui aux
deux tiers
et puis voici quelques commentaires pour
jf déconnectés de la réalité
elle ne cherche qu'à promouvoir leur
vision de la société idéale et souvent
par la même occasion leur carrière
beaucoup d'internautes nous disent comme
si je la gpa est au final déjà
programmés et brownie de l'odyssée
people anime le débat public dans le
sens où ils veulent juste se mettre sur
le devant de la scène les babineau
ajoute loyal robin s'érigeant porte
parole des français
je trouve cela assez déplacé peut-être
marin de viry que c'est parce que le
débat parce que ma politique est
difficile à organiser sur ces sujets par
exemple sur la pma ou
notamment les gens de droite j'en
connais quelques-uns qui sont plutôt
opposées ont pas envie de venir en
première ligne parce que ils ont ils
vont avoir l'impression de l'être contre
le progrès ou de pas avoir de coeur j'ai
pas d'être contre le progrès c'est de
savoir quelles que comme on dirait
qu'elle contrôle que l'on veut de la
technique dans son existence
voilà
c'est ça la gpa d'ailleurs comme la pma
de ce point de vue là c'est au fond ce
confié à la technique médicale
cette capacité humaine que nous avons de
reproduire
bon c'est un débat philosophique profond
la question de savoir si la technique
nous devons nous y soumettre nous y
soumettre ou en tout cas l'utiliser à
des fins qui sont des fins particulières
quoi voilà bon c'est pas un débat qui
peut être comme ça pose et enfin qui
doit être posée me semble-t-il avec
dignité avec et qui doit je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous qui doit
être posée à fond on doit parler de là
on doit parler là de la gpa dont on
parle est à fond
voilà et puis on verra ce qu'il en sort
et s'il en sort au fond que seul le
désir d'enfant est une sorte de le désir
d'enfant et le principe d'égalité entre
les couples homosexuels et les couples
hétérosexuels ça c'est plus
particulièrement pour la pme est quelque
chose qui voilà qui fait la loi à ce
moment là très bien c'est le désir
d'enfant et le principe d'égalité entre
homosexuels et hétérosexuels qui fait la
loi et ça n'est pas forcément l'idée
qu'on pourrait se faire de l'intérêt de
l'enfant d'avoir un père enfin une
origines paternelles et une origine
maternelle très bien mais au moins le
débat sera tranché poser comme ça et ça
aura été instruit de cette manière là et
d'autres manières aussi qu'ils sont
possibles mais c'est à ce niveau là
qu'il faut le faire venir c'est à ce
niveau de réflexion faut le faire c'est
pas chez machin là comment il s'appelle
donc ok écoutez c'est ce qu'on a essayé
de faire ce soir c'est de poser le débat
comme il convenait merci à tous les
casques de l'avoir permis point de vue
c'est fini pour ce soir à demain même
heure même endroit bonsoir à tous
[Musique]